later in the show I'm going to talk more
about the basket of deplorable that is
quickly uh accreting to be Donald
Trump's cabinet and advisors but real
quickly I want to tell you one quick
story about this we've seen over the
years from Republican presidential
candidates a list of departments and
agencies that they want to eliminate
this is a really popular thing for
Republican candidates to do and for
former Texas Governor Rick Perry it was
the departments of commerce education
and energy and it turns out that former
Texas Governor Rick Perry is being
considered for Secretary of Energy he
wanted to make it so that the Department
of Energy no longer existed here in this
clip he forgot the name department of
energy but we later learned that that's
that third department he couldn't
remember take a listen and I will tell
you it's three agencies of government
when i get there that are gone yeah
commerce education and the what's the
third one there let's see yeah 905 okay
so commerce education and the epa epa
there you go seriously
is he PA the one who were talking about
it no sir no sir we were talking about
the agencies of government ETA needs to
be rebuilt but you out about you can't
name the third one the third agency of
government i would i would do away with
the education uh the uh I'm right back
commerce and let's see I can't the third
what I can so okay so anyway later we
found out it was the Department of
Energy he wanted to do away with so Rick
Perry doesn't think that it should exist
but he might be appointed to run the
department you know you can't just close
it once you're the secretary right Rick
although I guess Pat the best way to
destroy a department is appoint someone
totally incompetent to run it right how
can we expect this guy to put his best
foot forward and running a department
that he wants to ultimately see close
the damn innocence also in the running
for energy secretary our new jersey
governor chris christie former alaska
governor and vice presidential candidate
Sarah Palin and an oil man named Harold
Hamm is there any situation where you
have to choose between Rick Perry chris
Christie Sarah Palin and an oilman and
it's not a disaster anytime you're
picking between those four you know
something went wrong right well here's
the kicker on the Department of Energy
contains the National Nuclear Security
Administration so these guys will have
the codes and very concerned they're
giving positions a way to well-known
Republicans I mean that did this is just
people that they like these are real
jobs that require experience and
knowledge and commitment and it's been
turned into a complete joke this is
idiocracy there is no other way to say
it and by the way Trump
anti-establishment his entire staff and
cabinet is establishment from what we've
learned so far uh it's possible Trump
may have lied about that entire I will
be a Washington outsider and go against
the grain because it is not happening
later in the show we'll dig into some of
the deplorable selections Trump is
already made about who will be advising
him and serving at donalds pleasure for
the next four years we'll take a break
i'm on twitter at d pakman back after
this warby parker is offering a free
five day home try-on to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses i
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm
not wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick 5
pairs that i liked put them on in the
comfort of my own home pick the one I
like the most and then Warby Parker put
my prescription lenses in there for me a
lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing